andré lesueur bonjour bonjour vous venez
de remporter la présidence de l'espace
sud la communauté d'agglomération du sud
durant les six prochaines années vous
allez disposer d'un budget de 177
millions le troisième budget en termes
de volume de nos collectivités
alors tout d'abord vous attendiez à
cette victoire c'est pas la première
fois que vous présentez vous été un peu
surpris nos pas le moins du monde parce
que j'ai fait campagne
je me suis battu je suis allé sur le
terrain et je crois qu'il est tout à
fait normal que les résultats suivent
alors l'espace sud a pas mal de défis à
affronter une fois que vous serez arrivé
je vais prendre votre poste la priorité
des priorités qu'elle souhaite qu'elle
sera t-elle pour d'abord nous allons
constituer une équipe
ma conception du management c'est le
travail en équipe
c'est le partage et la co construction
je pars avec mes gros sabots jo super
président non je le dis très simplement
s'il n'ya pas de commune y aura pas une
communauté donc l'appui le substrat ça
sera les communes et la communauté ne
sera pas la 13e commune donc l'équipe va
se mettre au travail avec bien
évidemment un capitaine d'équipé une
locomotive pour entraîner et les joints
tout le reste
en utilisant les 177 millions de la
manière la plus pragmatique voire la
plus réaliste possible
parmi les défis il ya le traitement des
déchets et eau surtout la question de la
distribution de l'eau vous avez déjà un
plan d'attaqué
alors je ne ferai pas ça tout seul je le
sais j'ai déjà pris langue avec comité
citoyen avec monsieur lannoy
j'ai rendez vous dès ce mercredi avec
mes collègues de
la cacem et de cap nau et je pense que
nous avons déjà commencé à mettre tout
sur la table
je pense évidemment qu'il faut la créer
un groupe de travail une commission
quelque chose de ce genre pour tenter
d'appréhender ensemble cette
problématique qui est importante et
cruciale concernant toujours cette
question de l'eau le comité citoyen sud
a réclamé un dégrèvement de près de deux
mètres de paiement de leurs factures
votre réponse ce serait le doux chant
qu'est ce que je sais qu'il ya déjà des
négociations entamées par mon
prédécesseur
ça ne relève pas de la responsabilité
directe de l'espace sud mais on va se
parler et voir ce qu'il est possible de
faire ça a coûté de l'argent puisque
c'est autant d'argent qui n'entrera pas
dans les caisses de l'espace il faudra
voir comment ensemble avec leurs aux
appréciations leur participation en tout
cas comment appréhender cette histoire
alors lé maire de rivière pilote et de
cette l'ue se sont entendus pour
résoudre ensemble les problèmes comme de
leur ville vous pensez que c'est une
initiative à encourager mais ça nous a
fait depuis longtemps sait très peu de
choses
seulement il y avait un bras de fer
entre le maire de sainte-luce et le
président de l'espace une des chaunois
pu régler par le dialogue et les chars
eurent marron le froides dès que
possible
en parlant de dialogue vos homologues de
la cacem et notamment de cap nord ont
décidé qu'ils étaient prêts à vous
donner la main pour travailler ensemble
il ya des axes de collaboration ans se
voit mercredi à 11 heures à 11 heures
mercredi
oui par exemple à la casse m d'accord
dans le nord ils ont réussi un petit peu
à régler la question de l'eau est ce que
les solutions trouvées dans le nord sont
elles le transposable dans le sud
vous avez l'exemple de ceux de libye il
faut voir ce à l'échelle martiniquaise
on parle de l'autorité unique
il faut voir ça ensemble chacun dans son
coin ça n'apportera rien du tout il faut
mettre tout sur la table et voir par
quel bout en attaque on prend ce
problème étant entendu qu'on ne doit pas
avoir toutes les solutions pour tout
régler à la fois mais il ya des chemins
du possible sont ouverts alors il ya
la spa sud dispose d'un bureau de 21 ans
membre sur 49 élus du conseil
communautaire s'est pas trop lourd à
gérer ça le bureau s'est d'abord 4 14
vice-présidents et six délégués bon ou
plus on est nombreux mieux on partage
mieux l'imagination sera aux
responsabilités la force de travail
aussi à force morale l'esprit
d'initiative et tout ça il faudra le
canaliser et puis le mettre en musique
six nouveaux maires ont été élus dans le
sud
c'est un vrai renouvellement de dans la
zone des bars ya beaucoup de mecs ils se
sont pas représentés et les normales
cinq d'ailleurs souhaitable que y ait
des nouveaux qui arrivent je suis encore
là parce que les anciens qui est la
population l'a voulu me l'a presque
imposé mais nous on ne ferait pas de
vieux os ni à l'espace et demi à la
ville de rio salée la relève est là j'ai
douze nouveaux germes on verra pas mieux
qui veut prendre la suite
andré lesueur merci c'est moi